on m'a recommandé vos
services vous avez l'habitude on ne
donne pas son nom on ne donne pas
d'info et on donne son téléphone à qui
elle est cette gamine à un homme très
riche qui va se retrouver avec millions
en
moins je suis là pour qu'il t'arrive
rien comment tu t'appelles moi c'est
Abigael tu peux m'appeler Joy tu as des
enfants j'ai un petit garçon je vous
laisse on se donne rendez-vous dans 24
he tu sais ce que ça veut dire premis
juré si tu es sage et que tu fais ce
qu'on dit premis juré tout sera bientôt
fini Joé
oui je suis vraiment désolée de ce qui
va
t'arriver
[Musique]
[__] merde faut sortir
d'ici je crois qu'elle cache quelque
chose ça craint ça craint ça
craint on
déend mais [__] c'est quoi ce truc et
ben on a kidnappé un vampire
un vampire qui fait de la danse
classique ok comment on tu un vampire tu
veux la méthode
trwilight un P en plein cur la lumière
du jour ça marche aussi d'accord tout ce
qu'on a à faire c'est buter un vampire
prê
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis comme ça j'aime bien jouer avec
ma
[Musique]
nourriture
ça me fait chier la
danse